ça va j'ai besoin de me remettre au
travail
je la dépose et tu la récupères tu es la
meilleure on compte sortir une nouvelle
collection très bientôt comment ça va en
ce moment Christine
après ces histoires
bonjour Christine excusez-moi on se
connaît je suis là pour vous aider c'est
vous qui m'avez appelé j'ai oublié vous
êtes dur à la tâche de vos oui Christine
je suis dure à la tâche
je peux l'aider
Diana c'était quoi ça
je peux vous aider vous devez me faire
confiance je veux que vous arrêtiez de
la manipuler comme vous le faites
-le cette maison est à moi et j'aime pas
la partager avec une vendeuse de poudre
soi-disant magique vous êtes là
vous êtes forte
vous vous sentez bien
évidemment
[Musique]
vous êtes prête Christine
vous êtes prêtes à affronter ce qui est
en vous
il est temps que vous voyez
et que vous compreniez enfin